so without further ado i want to
introduce uh rodrigo uh our umbreo
who's our who's our speaker here he's
gonna give a really really great talk
about
all things gpus and data science
um so what i'll do is i'll turn over to
rodrigo now and then
we're gonna mute everybody's uh mic so
that way he's got the floor
if you have some questions put it in the
chat window um
and then uh we'll address them at the
end and then we'll all come come back
uh after that so enjoy
all right well thanks aaron um here i'm
gonna put my screen share
oops i think i muted him to shoot
okay how about now can you hear me now
yeah i muted you i muted everybody and
you that's
sorry about that that's groovy no
worries um i'm guessing you guys can see
my screen now right
yep okay well just to introduce myself
um thanks aaron for the for the
introduction i'm rodrigo
i'm the co-founder and the ceo of
blazing sql
and basically we've been working on gpu
accelerated sql
for about six years which puts us
basically at the beginning when
a lot of gpu accelerated sequels started
coming out for the first time we thought
about it very differently
um and about two years ago or a little
over two years ago we started working
on an open source data science ecosystem
for gpus
with nvidia and that work ended up
building the fundamentals of our now
open source sql distributed sql engine
um so real quick things here um
you know check us out on twitter if you
want to hear about what we're doing
what's going on we post all sorts of
information about
uh blazing sql at twitter so at blazing
sql if you have any questions after this
talk
uh you can message me directly rodrigo
at blazing sequel
um and yeah we'll just um
we'll just get into it so to kind of
start things out
it's really important to understand
rapids and what rapids is about so for
anyone not necessarily familiar
rapids is a gpu data science ecosystem
where you can do end-to-end workflows
from
you know raw data living inside maybe
it's you know
aws s3 buckets and a bunch of apache
parquet files
or thousands or millions of csv files
what what have you
all the way down to whatever it is that
you're trying to do so you have to do
etl to that data and then maybe you have
to do some machine learning you have to
do visualization you have to do graph
analytics
uh deep learning etc but keeping it all
entirely inside the gpu
has always been kind of like the big
thing about rapids and what that enables
it to do is to run
you know dramatically faster you can use
a lot less hardware
um to be able to do you know big scale
analytics and
and that's really like the whole purpose
of rapids in the rapids ecosystem
uh real fast everything in the rapids
ecosystem is open source
apache v2 super permissible licenses
um everything in the rapids ecosystem is
gpu accelerated
um that's obvious because nvidia is the
largest contributor we're the second
largest contributor to rapids
um and then the other big thing about it
is the apis so many of the apis and the
packages that have been created
in rapids mirror pi data ecosystem or
similar you know a lot of really common
popular apis
so the whole idea is to be able to just
take the code that you know
and love today change out some import
statements ideally
and that'll just run on gpus
dramatically accelerated
now that's the pitch and you can do a
lot of things like that but
you know they're they're this is a 0.14
project um so there's obviously still a
lot of things that we have to build out
um but it can do a lot of a lot of that
to quickly kind of go over the rapids
ecosystem this is just kind of like a
high level and this
this isn't even really um exhaustive
anymore
of the whole ecosystem because there are
just so many components that exist now
uh but these are kind of the few the
original few
um and what really matters about this
whole ecosystem
is that there's basically a data frame
that's held inside
apache aero gpu memory and
what that means or what that enables us
to do is that we're able to very
performantly
hand off data frames between all the
different libraries inside the ecosystem
without having to copy the data between
them without having to serialize
the information between them and it just
makes it just a holistically more
seamless experience
so we're the sql engine of this entire
ecosystem so we're sql on data frames
is the easiest way to think about us um
qdf
is the pandas-like api so for etl
pick your poison it doesn't matter which
you really prefer if you prefer pandas
there's a pandas like api
if you like sql there's a sequel api um
and that's like the two main etl
libraries
qml is scikit-learn on gpus
also mirrors the apis coup graph is
network x
if you're familiar with network x for
graph analytics and then there are
plugins to pi torch chainer and a bunch
of other deep learning stack
um as well as visualization and this
really isn't all of it there's also now
there's a crew spatial package
which is all about gis on gpus so
you know if you're trying to do things
with 5 million
or 100 million uh geo coordinates like
it's
incredibly fast and highly performant um
there's also coo signal which is for
like sigma processing there's a bunch
there's new new projects being added
all the time and the entire impetus for
building up this ecosystem in this stack
was trying to figure out a way that we
can enable
python data science to not just be
performant in the small scale factor you
know for a couple of gigabytes
but how is it that you scale it up
effectively to terabyte workloads
and something that's here right is desk
so desk is really consequential
in making that happen and desk is
basically what brings this whole
ecosystem together to run
on multi-gpus so you know maybe i want
to start out with one gpu on my laptop
start playing around but then i can
start taking it further and further with
more gpus using desk
so kind of just like a really good
demonstration of why this ecosystem
matters
the the way that we always pitch it is
faster cheaper easier
that's that's the whole idea most of the
time when people hear gpus cheaper is
the last thing
that they think because gpus are really
quite expensive pieces of hardware
but if you know how to utilize them and
utilize them effectively you actually
could have a
dramatically lower uh cost of ownership
for a variety of workloads so this right
here is a
benchmark by this organization called
tpc and
their benchmark tpc xb is their big data
benchmark
and basically there are 30 workflows the
the data set mirrors
uh a retail and e-commerce store
and what they basically do is they have
these 30 different workloads and those
workloads will be
from etl to natural language processing
etl to machine learning it's all a
variety of different workloads that try
to mimic what this
retail and e-commerce site would would
necessarily have to do
and lets you just scale up the data sets
uh to really large data sets
so we we ended up running this benchmark
and the current winner for one terabyte
space
is huawei with cloudera um implemented
on it
and for about half the price so they
were costing you know
about 280 000 for their 16 server
cluster
we were able to do something on half the
price worth of infrastructure
and we're on average about 44 times
faster
um on this particular workload this is a
log scale
chart so it's you know bear in mind that
this here is like 44x
faster this here is like 200x i kind of
just
picked five of the workloads i picked
the two fastest or the two
the two that had the biggest speed up
which are these two over here which are
in like the 200 range
um the two with the slowest speed up
which are you know like five to ten
sort of speed up range and then this
one's about the average
45 like 45 times faster but that's
really what the whole concept of this
ecosystem is right it's about
one can we run the workloads faster to
can we run the road loads cheaper
and then when we start thinking about
easier that's really what comes up
in the in the next parts of this so
data frames on gpus is kind of like the
first thing we like to talk about
just because it's the first part of a of
a data science pipeline
and qdf is really kind of like the thing
that connects
everything in the ecosystem together um
so it's pandas
on gpus that's literally the easiest way
to think about it
and how it works and so here just this
is just a really simple code snippet
um showing what it's like to write it if
you know pandas which
for this meetup i'm going to assume
pretty much everyone here does or
at least 90 percent of us do um
this should look very obvious and simple
to you it's just the dot read csv
and it's a data frame and this is
entirely on gpu memory
um some really good numbers these are
all numbers from nvidia
so you know gpu speed up over cpu they'd
normally try to find a server class cpu
with a server class gpu
to do these kind of comparisons but
across a variety of different workflows
right or
or algorithms you'll see that the speed
ups are almost
three orders of magnitude in some cases
and that's really just like this is the
data frame
it's on gpu you're able to operate on it
a lot faster
um and then you can hand off that data
frame kind of like pandas to anything
that supports the ecosystem blazing is
sql
on data frames so that same data frame
that
we did previously or we showed off
previously
we can also just pass that as a table
and if we name that
as a table inside blazing sql we can
effectively just write sql
on top of it we leverage an open source
project called apache cal site
which is our sql parser so we're
actually ansi sql compliant
compliant does not mean complete so
there's still you know sql functionality
that we don't
we don't enable particularly ddl if
you're familiar with sql so you know any
data definition language all of that's
pythonic
for our engine the entire engine itself
that's probably something
i should have mentioned at the beginning
the entire engine itself is a python
engine
so you can't install blazing sql you're
not connecting it to a database
or a sql engine or something that exists
somewhere else that package has
everything in it
and then you're literally going to just
be calling python functions
to run sql and i'll show that off in
some demos uh
in a few minutes uh this isn't this is
basically just um
an explanation about atticore i'm not
going to get too into this
what really matters in this in this
particular slide is that
blazing sequel knows how to operate and
cache in between execution kernels so if
we have a query execution plan on let's
say a terabyte of data
and we only have one gpu on our laptop
but we have a ton of let's say disk
space we're able to cache either you
know to system memory
or to disks uh to drives right
um as we're doing execution so you can
scale up
pretty aggressively even if you only
have a few gpus so
something that really happens
particularly in qdf
is that qdf expects everything to fit
inside of a gpu whenever you're
operating on it
and so we're using the same primitives
as qdf but we break up
on sql land it's a lot easier to break
up you know how to work on these
particular things or how to work on a
sql plan
um and so we've we've done it so that
you can basically be operating on these
out of core
uh queries we actually have a blog post
that talks a little bit about a 10
terabyte workload
that we did on one gpu um it obviously
runs slower you want it to go faster you
have to add more gpus
but that's that's how that works
real fast um so desk is kind of the
thing
that brings it all together when we're
trying to think about scaling out this
gpu architecture
so when it comes to pandas for example
on on gpus the qdf library
very similar to a dash data frame is
made up of a bunch of partitions of
pandas data frames there's a very
similar
implementation called das qdf and das
qdf
is a top-level project inside the
ecosystem it's wildly important
and it's how all of these qdf data
frames are
handled in a partitioned environment you
know so if i have
eight gpus i'll have eight partitions of
pdfs that
with one of them residing on each gpu
each worker effectively
blazing sql also leverages to ask qdf
um for one this distributed data frame
so if you run a blazing sql query the
results of a blazing sql query aren't
going to be
brought back to a single worker um
depending on the type of sql query that
you have it might be the results that
might be distributed across your array
of workers
and when we do that we don't create just
a cdf we have a das qdf
that has it on the other side the other
thing that's really interesting about
desk is desk is how we maintain
awareness
of the cluster so you don't tell blazing
sql to run on
you know 10 different gpus or 10
different servers
you simply create a desk client
that has awareness of that has those has
desk workers on all those different gpus
and blazing sql will just learn where
all the cl
where all those uh workers are and then
launch a blazing sql worker process
on all of them and das is really what
enables that to work
um so we don't just use it for the cuda
data for the partition data frame
we also use it for that and then desk
qml is basically you know
just like desk ml except leveraging uh
desktop for anyone who's not familiar
with desk ml
it's it's a distributed version of a
bunch of machine learning projects
das qml does the same thing so you can
effectively think of this as like
scikit-learn with das but it's all
running on gpus
and it can also take these you know data
frames that are partitioned
that are partitions of qdfs and and
that's how das kind of brings this thing
into into this ecosystem
um i'm going to real quickly go over
machine learnings and then i just want
to
i want to bring up a demo so everyone
can follow along
um cool ml like i was saying
is scikit-learn or sk learn for for gpus
so anyone who's familiar with sklearn
literally if we just changed out this
the the text in red here
this would totally function the only
difference is that this is happening
on gpus and that's the whole proposition
of of like this this workload so we can
you know
create data frames off of raw data etl
it transform it do all sorts of things
and then hand it off to cool mal
for doing machine learning um
just real quick you know showing off a
variety of different things that have
already been implemented
in qml these are a variety of the
different algorithms
that you can get um and they're growing
by the day there's a pretty big team at
nvidia that actually
writes a ton of this incredibly smart
group uh
crew and and yeah all of this is uh
this is a really interesting project
inside inside the rapids ecosystem
um before i go you know what instead of
going over more slides i kind of want to
just show off some demos
of how this all works and one of the
cool things is that people can follow
along
if they would like to um so
if you go to app.blazingsql.com
what you're going to have is basically
it's an app that has a hosted jupyter
lab environment
it'll create a unique private jupyter
lab environment
but we're all going to be sharing gpus
across a cluster of gpus
so if anyone feels like during the demos
querying a giant data set they know
about
uh you might crash a friend or two and
be a nasty neighbor so just keep that in
mind
but but otherwise you're more than
welcome to sign in
you have to have a google account that's
one of the one of the things that you
have to do
but you can see how this whole how this
whole thing works
um so let's see
if i can get in
all right here we go so i'm just gonna
real fast to show off a few different
things
this is basically the environment that
you'd be brought into
and one of the things that i always like
to show people is
there's a jupiter lab extension in here
that lets you
monitor gpu resources and
assuming it loads up you can actually
see the gpu ticking here
but right now it's not coming up so we
won't let's
oh there it is so yeah so i highly
recommend pulling this up you literally
just have to click gpu resources and
then you can click and drag it to the
right
but if you're new to gpu execution i
love doing this just so that you can see
what you're doing
um and what we're gonna do and you're
more than welcome to follow along
is there's a welcome notebook so inside
the directory welcome to blazing sql
notebooks
if you just open up the welcome notebook
you can see
what's going on here so i'm just going
to give a second
in case anyone's trying to follow along
just open up the welcome notebook
and then we don't need to go through all
this text here this basically just does
a little bit of explanation
about the ecosystem and everything that
goes on we're just going to run straight
to
to uh some actual work so
if you're familiar with pi spark or
spark at all the blazing context is
basically are similar to a spark context
it manages state of the engine and knows
what's going on
and it's also where you kind of create
tables register storage plugins or
external file systems
and do all sorts of different things so
we're just going to create this context
and once this context is done
creating which normally it should happen
really quite quickly
but there might be something that's
holding us back right now
here we'll give this just a second
while we're doing that i wanted to see
if there are any questions around
getting up and running in here
all right i think i know what's going on
this is a new server we turned on a
bunch of servers and so the first time
that it
imports a package on one of the brand
new servers it takes a little while
so i'll just walk through what's
happening here while we're waiting for
it
to bring all the packages in um
but basically we're creating this
context and
once we create that context we can start
registering tables there
so with a create table you know
we put the name of the table we put a
file path
as to where it is and this actually
isn't even necessary because it'll infer
that there's a header row and once we
create a table off of this
uh off of the csv file we can just query
it
directly um
man i was really hoping that this thing
would have gotten running by now
let's see i just want to see i have a
question that you can answer in the
meantime
that would be awesome yeah so is it
possible to place
blazing in front of postgres what's the
question
yeah so as of right now uh not
technically i mean there are ways to do
it
because we can run queries off of pandas
data frames as well
assuming that you have um that you have
a gpu on your
on your server or on your on your
computer
but that's the best way to do it if you
can do a postgresquery into pandas and
then
run a query off of that that's great
right now the thing that we support
creating tables off of are raw files
and in memory data format so pandas pi
arrow kudiaf etc
we've started opening up to things
beyond
just files uh and the first of that is
hive
so you can actually pass a hive cursor
into
into the create table statement as
opposed to a file path or a data frame
and that'll also work um so hive is the
very first one that we've enabled
but you can't do it on postgres or mysql
or anything yet
so so it just ran so i'm gonna just show
this off then
um and for anyone else you probably had
that delay if you got put on a new
server and you wouldn't have had any
delay if you were put on one of the
older ones
um but this is what a sql statement
looks like for blazing sql
it's literally just a bc.sequel you know
also super similar if you're familiar
with pi spark
you can put in your sql into it and then
what actually returns here
is one of these qdfs or one of these
data frames so then you can start doing
whatever it is that you want to do
with one of these with one of these qdfs
and just to kind of show that off
you know i'm going to start launching
these in case
just to show that off right the type of
query
is literally one of these creative data
frames so if i have something that can
plug into a qdf data frame
that's all i need to be able to get it
just this bc dot sql statement
and you can see as we're clicking and
executing things here i'll even do this
again just to show it off
you know we see a spike in gpu
utilization and so that's how you know
that
if you've never run gpu code you just
did it right like hey
congrats it's a big day for all of us
um but going forward right
you've got you've got codia so beyond
blazing sequel there's more right so qdf
is the other package
again if you're familiar with pandas
this should all look very similar to you
but just like i was showing before a
blazing sql statement
is returned to kudia so this is how we
can make a data frame as
well with blazing sql and you can do all
sorts of things that you would expect
pandas to be able to do
right so you can do doctail you can do
describe and look at the
descriptive statistics on it you can
run excuse me you can run filtering
you know just like you would on on
append as data frame
and all of this all this is happening on
gpu
right what's also really cool
is because this data frame is this qdf
it has a really nifty function called
dot 2 pandas so if you're trying to
enable
qdf to do things that aren't necessarily
supported in the rapids ecosystem
you can literally just convert it into a
pandas data frame so now right here we
have a pandas data frame and you can run
you know that sample on it
to grab some random rows
taking it to database so i'm going to
hope everyone's relatively
following along if they're if they're
trying to follow along so we're still in
the welcome notebook and now we're at
the data visualization section
so again if this is a qdf
and this whole thing is a pandas and
you're familiar with pandas plotting
um or you like pandas plotting which
according to my breakout room i don't
think anyone like panda's plotting but
i'm assuming somebody must enjoy it um
you can literally just run whoops i
don't know what sent me
all the way up there there we go you can
literally just run this
command and again this is just a panda's
data frame now in here
and you can start plotting blazing sql
queries or qdf data frames
however it is that you want to another
really awesome
project data shader datashader is one of
the first projects
that um started integrating qdf
as a as a data frame that you can
actually visualize and render
visualizations off of
so here we're running a sql statement
off of
the new york city yellow cab taxi
dataset you're not familiar with the new
york city yellowcab taxi dataset it's
just a big data set
um of taxi rides drop
off and pick up spots and here we're
literally just grabbing the drop off
coordinates and then rendering them
in data shader and you can see that we
don't do anything special
to the data frame we literally just pass
it in as an argument
to data shader and it knows how to
render a qdf
and so it's able to run what's even
cooler is
it also knows how to render a das qdf um
so if you're doing this in a distributed
context on you know lots of gpus and the
data set is
dramatically larger you can also be
passing it one of these to ask qds
as opposed to a normal qdf
and then the last one in here and this
is just like our welcome notebook to
show things off very quickly
is cool and so here
this is literally just for sake of you
know simplicity and trying to get people
to do their first cool ml
algorithm this is um we're just doing a
linear regression
and off of that same taxi
yellowcab dataset that we were talking
about we can extract
the information that we need into data
frames this
this statement right here i really like
because it kind of shows how you can mix
and match
pandas functionality with sql
functionality to be able to get exactly
what you want the way that you want it
um and then here let's just run that
it's gonna have to bring this one in
so yeah that's gonna probably take a
little while so we'll just keep going
for a little bit
um let me see so yeah
there it is so this is how we create the
data set
with coolml very similar to scikit-learn
we can
we can do train test split so that we
can break up that data set
into training data and test data and
then
we can basically hand that data off to
this linear regression model
doing this fit and then this prediction
on it
and so we just run it
normally it doesn't take that long i'm
not necessarily certain
what's slowing this down today i think
it's something on the storage layer
but you know what we'll let this keep
running for a second
but this is effectively what what the
whole ecosystem brings together right
you have this qdf data frame you can
generate it with sql
you can generate it with pandas like api
uh you can pass it on
to dataviz you can pass it off to coolml
that should not have taken there we go
that's what it should have taken it
should have taken 34 milliseconds um
yeah we'll just run this again real fast
just to make sure nothing was weird
yeah there we go so that's how fast that
should have run
um because it's really not that large of
the data set
and yeah that's that's like a quick tour
of uh
of the rapids ecosystem um like i said
this
uh this notebook application has
everything you need to
to get up and running we actually enable
you to have either um
you know what we call rapid stable and
rapids nightly i highly recommend using
the rapid stable build this is basically
every official release
that comes out of blazing or not just
blazing sql but also the entire rapids
community
and it's just one that goes through a
really a serious amount of testing
rapids nightly is the merging of all the
prs
like building all the pr's that got
merged that day
and so we do our best to run a series of
test scripts for this app
to make sure you have a good experience
but that's not guaranteed
uh because it is a nightly build um so
things can break all the time but if you
want to try the latest and greatest
that's coming out of rapids and blazing
sequel this is the environment
that you want to launch so just to wrap
things up
um real fast this is a fully
open source community so first and
foremost you know
github we're always looking for issues
feature requests
anything that breaks it breaks all the
time it's breaking a little bit less
today than it was breaking yesterday and
we hope to keep doing that over the next
uh
you know a few years but yeah we
actually had someone on this talk
uh i'm gonna give a shout out ray bell
attended a talk the other day
and put the first uh put his first
feature request
uh for an issue in our github and we're
super duper appreciative of that
um but it's not just blazing db rapids
ai
also has a bunch of repos um like qdf
cool ml
etc we also appreciate issues being
filed there
and also desk uh and the seven cloud
crew i'm sure they they appreciate desk
issues
um all the time uh
follow us on twitter right blazing sql
rapids ai
those are the big accounts we post
everything and anything that's going on
in the ecosystem there first
um typically well before we have the
time
or energy to write a blog post about it
so
if you're interested in knowing what's
going on that's a really good place
slightly later than the stuff on twitter
is the blog itself
so blog.blazingdb.com
and we also have this this this uh
rapids academy which is basically a
place for people to learn
about rapids and everything that's going
on uh so you can check it out at
learnrapids.com
and yeah just going over over things
real quickly about how you can get
started
the condo package you can install qdf
blazing sql
qml whatever it is you you want via
conda
and get started today blazing sql
notebooks has this already
and we already have we have aws
marketplace instances
that come with the whole rapids
ecosystem um if you're looking to deploy
it like that
and with that i think that's time
so yeah i know i
kind of went rapid fire it's 30 minutes
trying to go over a little bit too much
content
probably but i'd love to see if there
are any questions